hello and welcome to CEO playing E coli
past Zhukov
okay well it's Nikolai up to against my
deep on nothing
I know a place okay just playing
something in one theoretical I have no
clue yet it should be should be decent
okay okay it's seven here this is not
uncommon in many Slav lines
hmm not sure about it
not sure to play if I should go c5 and
Bishop f4 here it's often the thing to
do against those a 6b7 setups Knight e4
okay does he want to go g5 even here
maybe maybe I want to get rid of the
knight on e4
yeah he's very close to managing if I've
gotta go here and now what do you do
here maybe this one intending be five
and then some quickie for against it
okay so he wants to trade it
submit lame though if I go Bishop f4
that's a tough call if you go back here
or not
I mean he's playing instantly the whole
time maybe it's got a bit of a better
knowledge there about this position type
compared to meme Queen a5 so he really
wants to go a 5 that is a quite quite
clear
[Music]
I can take em play Bishop C to a stupid
stop
I saw it immediately after making the
move and he has spotted us it's not
exactly rocket science
Bishop C - he has not spotted it okay
[Music]
and then then it's still okay and it's
still okay for me
My dear supply F for now okay so he
finally has made two smooth
I wonder if it is actually a good idea
to go to b6 there there could be
something that is leading to nothing
ultimately it is probably absolutely
nothing going on
I have an idea with rook d4 before it's
okay it's not it's not going to be
better for me or anything
maybe maybe I should also just get this
night reroute it to deform
[Music]
I don't think he's got a discovery yeah
this is absolutely true
what a horrible game what I played a
really horrible game
Ruki three is also very strong
yeah it's totally lost footage okay can
still make some moves look each one for
example is very simple
it's a case where basically everything
wins
hmm wow that was an absolutely atrocious
game I actually think I had to add a
nice position I mean it was so it was
just a little bit better for me but I
played it so badly that this happened I
can just push the pawns home there is
just I got absolutely zero playing
and ads and no good Jam absolutely no
good to skim he thought around him I'm
quite okay computer says equal yeah I'm
willing to believe that but I mean it
was still fairly normal position and he
was going back and forth basic lame I
didn't didn't do all that much there
should be seven yeah probably I should
trade this the engine also likes me for
the whole time which I don't believe is
good really and then that is an
evaluation that I don't quite understand
the engine says and that this is
supposed to be better for me
and this is tough to believe I think
yeah maybe maybe I'm here this is
something that I can't believe I can go
here and this is a bit of pressure but
still not much and maybe this is better
it's okay I mean I may have made many
mistakes Queen a4 was was just bad I
mean quick Queenie fibers also makes no
sense really but Queen a4 is kind of the
justification and I'm just create for is
terrible and he missed the simple Bishop
c2 which just wins the game played this
instead and now it's equal until I'm
allowed this allowed this transformation
down with before and so on that for
sells bad
here here it's just equal ish I don't
think when black black is a slight
advantage has side ones according to the
combat it's not much it's not much and
I'm just running into this and it's
immediately lost its immediately lost
you have no no way - no way to
consolidate it's quite funky that I got
no blunders here in this check yeah
that's it that's a joke i blundered so
much in this game the ante I'm just
completely completely toast yeah I mean
again I didn't know the opening well but
so here I should play Knight Age form it
makes it awful lot of sense I just kept
the bishop pair for Zyliss probably
something like this is just going to be
good for me I guess and you can
sometimes open up with efore favorably
now yeah I'm better I'm just better him
something like this and then some efore
take and inform no g5 winning okay
winning really can take here already
Oh
and wide wins crazy I mean okay I like
has to move so something I have to play
something like Knight age 4 in such a
position that is important he never
played age 6 and this could be a reason
why age 6 is often played yeah a really
really bad game but probably some
instructive moments nevertheless thanks
for watching